توجهنا مع المقاتلين الى مدينه مارينكا
الملتهبه بالمعارك شمال غربيه مقاطعه
دانيت تنتقل وفاه المقاتلين لارض المعركه
عبر حاملات الجنود سيرا على الاقدام لوسي
المدينه الذي سيطر عليه الجيش الروسي
الهدف هو الوصول الى فنادق خط المواجهه
الاول
اثار المعارك الضاريه وساخنه التي شهدتها
هذه المدينه مدينه مارك خلال الاشهر
الماضيه حيث سيطره الجيش الروسي على جزء
كبير من هذه المدينه الحديث عن ثلثي
المدينه والمتبقي الثلث الاخير وهي
الابنيه الشاهقه سرنا كاسراب النمل حذرين
من الالغام بمحاذاه الجدران خشيه القناصه
في الثلث الاخير من المدينه يشتبك
المقاتلون بالبنادق وضعنا كاميرا على خرده
مقاتل خلال عمليات الاقتحام التي تهدف
لاكمال السيطره على المدينه
نادي الرساله
بعيد
[موسيقى]
على ضوء شمعه والدبابات تقصف موقعنا عبر
المسيرات
مر الدقائق الليل كالسنين بانتظار بزوق
الفجر على اثير الرشاقات الرصاص والصواريخ
ينفذ الجيش الروسي عمليات اقتحام في مدينه
ماركا الكائنه شمال الغرب مقاطعه دانيت
اليوم بالذات القوات الخاصه الروسيه تنفذ
عمليه اقتحام على هذه الابنيه ذات الخمسه
الطوابق نسمع اصوات الاشتباكات
بالاسلحه الخفيفه وايضا اصوات القصب
المدفعي والقصف بالدبابات لقناتي العربيه
والحدث رائد الاخضر